on va profiter d'ailleurs cette occasion
si vous voulez bien pour rappeler aux
jeunes filles aux jeunes femmes qu'il
devient quand même un peu imprudent de
courir tout seul en forêt même si c'est
des itinéraires quand on connaît les
gens vous repère si vous passez la
plusieurs fois par semaine et ça peut
donner
l'idée à détraquer de vous attendre sur
votre parcours donc il faut absolument
que la course ça devienne une discipline
qu'on ne fait plus tout seul vous voyez
bien que toutes ces histoires c'est
jamais des hommes qui sont attaqués et
malheureusement quand ces femmes sont
attaqués souvent ça se termine assez mal
alors sacrée ouais je vous dire cette
phrase a créé une polémique je comprends
pas pourquoi me suis pas une polémique
s'il c'est à dire aux gars suit en fait
mais c'est la réalité
évidemment que ça fait une boulette
parce que ça va ça distille un sentiment
de peur ainsi que la sécurité dans la
population c'est vrai que les gens ils
disent balas lorsque site a une fille a
tout enlevé 10 va faire son footing
sympa qui là bas je dis pas qu'il a pas
raison mais je dis que c'est
effectivement je comprends que certaines
personnes disent voilà encore un
discours qui met en guerre qui met le
holà mais si mais si bien évidemment que
si après j'ai effectivement les forêts
où tu t'enfonces et pas prudent on le
sait mais ce n'est pas fait aujourd'hui
c'est depuis depuis tout le temps alors
ça c'est amusant tuez moi ça je vous
avais raconté ça m'est arrivé en juillet
2016 vous l'avait racontée par don kelly
non non je vous l'avait raconté que tu
veux j'ai été censuré par un marathonien
à neuilly à 8 heures du matin c'est pas
une zone dangereuse un prêt du centre
d'équitation et depuis chaque fois parce
qu il a ceinturé et ma ceinture et
m'allonger sur le sol voulez je vous
fasse un voilà il se passer quoi israël
ce que vous étiez enfin courir j'étais
en train de faire un footing comme quoi
ça n'arrive pas qu'aux jeunes encore à
quelle heure 8 heures du matin 8h du
matin au centre d'équitation voilà deux
doigts du bois de boulogne et de la
fondation vuitton et là le mec ma
ceinture et m'allonger sur le sur le sol
et ça a duré sa durée 2h30 donc où j'ai
vraiment subi ses assauts entre
guillemets et depuis chaque fois que je
vois une jeune femme s'enfoncer dans le
bois de boulogne j'ai envie de lui dire
ne court pas dedans ne court pas votre
boule mois depuis je ne court que dans
des axes où il ya beaucoup de gens mais
les fans de complot d'ailleurs depuis
deux ans vous avez porté plainte non
mais vous aviez engueuler parce que j'ai
pas parfait j'étais complètement soulier
de parts je suis rentré chez moi me
doucher après j'ai pas eu envie de
ressortir mais mais voilà donc oui
effectivement il a totalement raison moi
depuis ça c'est un truc qui m'obsède
comprend dix ans passés sur vous vous ne
courrez voir et puis depuis je cours
plus pessanha loustau pomerleau non mais
bon ça on va pas rigoler là dessus mais
c'est vrai que c'est quand même une
affaire grave et séries classiques prend
pas provenaient pas porter plainte
maintenant ça bouge là c'est quand vous
êtes tout ça les bains vous rentrez vous
vous doucher et vous restez et vous
restez chez parle à quelqu'un vous en
aviez parlé à votre mari et j'en ai
parlé à mon mari voilà qui sait que je
suis relativement solide donc voilà et
puis j'en ai parlé des copains qui ont
identifié le monsieur un ancien flic que
vous connaissez un chef alexandre qui a
identifié le avec will on connaissait le
flic oui pardon et qui est devenu
scénariste et depuis et voilà et puis
j'ai identifié monsieur dit oui c'est
bien lui et alors elle ne sait pas ne
pas porter plainte quoi voulez pas
retrouver monsieur ben j'ai pas voulu le
retrouver je me dis bon label de jay et
d'autre alors excusez moi ce que s'il le
fallait briser la même chose tous que la
dernière fois et excusez moi quand on
est à ce moment là et vous menez voilà
on se dit j'ai fait ce que je pensais on
n'est pas là du tout pour vous donner
des leçons pour dire qu'on pour s'avouer
en portions aux autres femmes et c'est
vrai que juste ça nous choque voilà ce
que vous nous racontez et parce qu'on
vous aime beaucoup parce que récompense
à toutes les autres femmes peut-être été
les autres victimes de ce monsieur s'il
est encore en liberté et c'est vrai que
si il faut un moment il faut essayer de
de leurs actes d'attraper cette personne
et et voilà de géraldine c'est vrai que
c'est ça que je me suis effectivement
mais effectivement pas culpabiliser isa
parce que dans pas du tout mais
mais bon voilà mais en tout cas moi je
t'ai on aimerait les dévoiler jeudi j'ai
dit comme le monsieur ne courait pas
sous les frondaisons me lancer elle ne
peut pas porter plainte à la place de
manille nous comme la d'informer faut
qu'elle déposerait bientôt
au moins une main courante oui il ya en
fait le pour moi le problème c'est pas
forcément ce qu'il dit et tous partagent
cet accord là quand vous êtes une femme
vous prenez beaucoup plus de risques en
étant un homme le problème c'est qu'ils
le disent et un général de la
gendarmerie il ya beaucoup de personnes
qui attendent de la police d' entendre
davantage la police va mettre ça en
place pour protéger des femmes que de
dire mais en fait alors juste arrêter de
vivre non non non
le truc tout fait ça c'est politique
ce qui fait polémique c'est surtout et
voilà il ya beaucoup de gens qui le dit
aussi si le fait de dire tu t'es fait
voilà genre il faut pas que tu dois
courir parce que oui tu peux avoir des
tenues la faute voilà c'est de ta faute
et ça ça tient j'espère qu'il n'a pas
dit dans ce sens là oui c'est ça qui
fait polémique mais c'est ça qui fait
polémique parce que genre fallait aller
faire son jogging tout seul dans cette
tenue voilà donc c'est assez sympa mais
on va bien voir ça ça veut dire que l'on
est une femme aujourd'hui on peut plus
rien faire non à celle que les victimes
n'ont pas à devenir les selles qui celle
par qui le problème est arrivée en
bourse ce serait de leur faute parce
qu'elle elle était au mauvais endroit et
on leur aurait dit 20 faire de noyal et
le mas si elles y vont quand même à
battre on a des prévenus non monsieur
voilà ça c'est absolument pas possible
en duo d'acteurs pourquoi elle fait
polémique cette phrase parce qu'il ya
deux manières de l'interpréter soit
c'est un triste constat et il a raison
il ya plus en plus de fans que
malheureusement seuls se font agresser
soit c'est à la limite du reproche la
dans la tournure de phrase rappeler aux
jeunes filles et aux jeunes femmes
limite on les culpabilise et c'est là
que ça peut faire polémique
non moi je trouve que c'est à la fois
enfin moi je suis d'accord avec ce qu'il
dit je trouve ça évidemment choquant
démoralisant est triste mais moralisons
et c'est démoralisant parce qu'on a
envie de pouvoir aller courir dans un
bois dans une forêt sans penser
forcément on va être poursuivi par un
prédateur sexuel pour d'écouter une
sonnerie cela mais moi personnellement
principe de précaution je pense que ceux
qui ont défié autour de la table sur à
aucun moment je vais lui dire à ma fille
va courir dans un bois dans les forêts
c'est cool jamais de la vie je serai
terroriser et dont elle lui interdirait
et voilà et donc je ferais exactement
comme ce général de gendarmerie et pour
autant je ne laisse toujours autant sert
à masquer l d'un legging ou un truc me
tant qu'on ne pense jamais à quel point
on est inférieure en force moi je vous
jure que quand on dire je vais lui taper
dans les parties et touba non non non il
vous paralyse complètement la force
physique ses voeux aucune en plus avec
la peur
c'est vrai ma considération
si on repense à la jeune fille qui a
disparu là elle avait une application
qui permet d'être localisé voyez et
malgré ça alors après on a su du coup
qu'elle avait été sans doute enlevé un
kilomètre de chez elle mais malgré ça
habitué au jogging toutes les
précautions près de chez elle elle a
sans doute été victime d'un prédateur on
se rassure l'anc est donc c'est très
dangereux moi si on ne s'en tient qu'à
la première fois ce que vous avez montré
je suis d'accord avec ces setec
gendarmes moi je vous dis très
franchement ma compagne fatou elles
courent en bord de mer je lui interdis
pas le faire fait ce qu'elle veut mais
je lui ai dit tu ne cours plus jamais
tout seul nous est plus jamais tout seul
est d'ailleurs parce qu il ya des
prédateurs qui rôde et ça il faut le
dire alors après bien entendu s'il ya
des reproches sur les tenues n'ont
jamais jamais mais il ya des prédateurs
qui rôde et c'est dangereux il faut se
méfier il faut vraiment être vigilant
aujourd'hui hélas eole et les familles
connaissent c'est une réalité que les
femmes connaissent et moi je connais
plein de groupes de filles qui ont qui
décide de courir ensemble
organisé en disant moi j'ai pas envie de
renoncer au jogging ou au footing parce
que c'est ma passion ça me fait du bien
j'en ai besoin mais bien on se donne
rendez-vous et on part à trois quatre
filles pour aller courir ensemble
ces surnoms melilla faire d'isabelle
c'est vrai que nous à chaque fois elle
nous la raconte à chaque fois on est on
est voilà ils sont bercés par par cette
affaire et c'est vrai que voilà ça ça
doit ça doit plus arriver en tout cas
l'histoire s'est bien terminée enfin
pour l'instant on dire que la jeune
fille evan bayh elle est en état de choc
mais la police tellement longtemps des
rations parce que psychologiquement ce
matin mais heureusement qu'on l'a
retrouvée vivante c'est quand même la
bonne nouvelle journée oui qu'il verse
100 gendarmes qui sont encore mobilisés
avec 200 à sa recherche est vraiment
chaque heure compte c'est à dire que ça
n'ont pas pu l'entendre parce qu'elle
est choquée ils n'ont pas pu faire ce
qu'on appelle une audition mais elle a
donné des bribes d'informations qui
permettent quand même d'orienter donc
vers cette camionnette deux hommes zahia
du porte à porte chez elle est près du
kebab où elle a été retrouvée pour que
tous les témoignages puisse permettre
d'identifier le ou les ravisseurs ne
prennent pas la fuite de soit arrêté
risque 20 ans de prison enlèvement
séquestration heureusement que voilà
heureusement et et 3 qui n'est
évidemment qu'ils ne réussiraient ils
peuvent pas tout est mis en oeuvre ayant
une expertise médicale aussi pour savoir
si apple et d'agréer
est notamment